new merch available it's an entirely
original concept you can finally embrace
that you're working at a fast-food
restaurant everybody whack Donald's it's
a place to be designed by me
hooray it's got Walmart quality it's a
limited offer and up dabbing let's begin
the video it's a video and we wanted to
make for a very long time I want to
check out my most popular videos I
haven't checked in a very very long time
it's one of those things I just don't
look at it said Wehling to the past and
I don't like it give you the three
phases of PT pi I look stupid cuz I
think I look pretty high hasn't it
English
[Music]
what a [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah I don't know if I like phase three
that's the thing is I know my most
popular videos are gonna be really old
you know what let's just get this over
with sort by most popular most people
associate a channel by their most
popular videos it it's pretty obvious a
funny montage 83 million views god damn
I had no idea if I had guessed I would
say it got 40 million views
how who's watching this and why five
years ago first of all if he calls
something funny it's immediately not
funny so this video should be great I
feel like the mother [ __ ] stuck in
this dog it makes me wanna quack like
what the [ __ ] is that this is where the
tower that's not right
you call that right Robin no no a good
example of loud equals funny you really
did it there Felix good job I love that
game that is a really good terrible you
can't even see what's going on I did
like how I had this heartbeat sensor
that's pretty cool that's pretty
original you always there beside me okay
fine this one is still funny
oh sure
why do you know what man I look so crazy
I look at me I look insane alright okay
it's funny it's kind of funny a lot of
it is cringy but i get why people think
it's funny my second most viewed video
is level level seven of scare PewDiePie
53 million views as stressful as these
were to film not just because of me
trying to keep up with everything that
was going on but also the show itself
like going through all these traumatic
experiences I always look back on it
like really fun memories they were good
times it's a shame they put this as the
the free episode cuz I think it's one of
the weaker ones I think just because it
was out last people thought it would be
cool 52 million views the Ruby play but
it's one of those video that haircut
Felix like what in the world I remember
the guy that gave me that haircut he was
like we're gonna do something different
I'm like oh okay I don't know what it is
with that is so fun exciting I really
wished I could just be an unboxing
channel that would just be so much fun
oh I guess there's really nothing
interesting here we really just I'm glad
we squeezed this one out to ten minutes
[Music]
and look people just want to know what
the award was it's a terrible video
funny gaming montage what is it six
years ago damn I think we're going here
should we just leave Jeremy what yes
Jeremy's brings these things to us sir
just like he always wanted that's my
dream with Oliver generally funny I
forgot about that
that's nice I'm glad I could genuinely
enjoy it a clip that's that's fantastic
this is great I thought I would just
courage that's hilarious Lok at the
entrance to out for labs for does it say
death is coming you don't know it's like
those moderately funny
perfect timing twitch donation montage
or whatever I don't know I guess I'm
done here
Jim Bob oh that was close whoa somebody
out there
like I'm I took the chair with me as
well they're not so bad kind of makes me
wish now I get it you're right you're
right you were right all along I think
people look at these montages and they
you know it's a snippet it's a three
second clip if I did a funny montage now
oh boy oh boy you be you be very happy I
was really not that funny next up we had
flappy bird I remember I play this game
and then right after it completely blew
up
I didn't even play flappy bird in this
video I played dumb ways to die which is
also an amazing game but then I
afterwards I play flappy bird bad sense
being the genius I am I changed the
title and the thumbnail to flappy bird
and there you go boom 35 million views
Thank You Felix
you greedy bastard next up we have the
video where I said I would delete my
channel the biggest is just a prank bro
in history I didn't think anyone would
actually believe me I didn't think
people would be like oh my god is he
actually gonna do it I don't even
remember why at least I don't remember
the reason why I think I remember in the
headspace I was I was really fed up with
being in the position I was it's two
months before the disaster I didn't like
being the biggest channel I didn't like
having so much attention to me I've said
it many times that I would rather just
be a smaller Channel so I could just do
my own thing and literally no one would
care like I never asked to be in this
position I genuinely felt like I can't
actually delete my channel and just
start a new one at that time I was
working with a lot of different people
you know I had companies and stuff like
that and I knew that if I believed my
channel it would be a huge replication
for
other people so I I knew I couldn't do
it but I did genuinely consider it
scared of PewDiePie never came out
anyway so you know I could have just
done it I should have just done it
Tammy next up we have my draw my life
video I got accepted to my first choice
of university and everything seemed fine
I started to become more creative
[Music]
that's really not a good video I feel
like I could have done that a lot better
then we have literally Jake Paul and
Logan Pole
I guess people like hearing so much on
Jake and Logan next up we had the
brofist by Rumi so when you upload every
single day if anyone comes to you and
say hey I can get you a video covered
for that day yes please yes I will take
it and Rumi came to me with this song
that he made he spent a long time on
this song and he did an amazing job on
it so I mean I get free previews Rumi
gets great exposure it's a talented dude
and yeah it's an amazing video I had
nothing to do with it literally nothing
[Music]
really good so
[Music]
no swear electric challenge the
impossible game good title Felix very
good title that actually hurts by the
way it genuinely hurts
don't use that on your own your kids I
almost said don't use that on your pets
and your kids oh look at me I'm like
crying oh this is a weird period in
YouTube where punishment and video game
was somehow a popular trend like the hot
pepper or hot sauce if you die or you
would do all these challenges it's just
like I'm glad that trend is over okay
because it was not fun this video got
demonetized
bigots damn it it's a great video I'm
not gonna show it it's hilarious you
should watch it it's basically me and
and Brad Pitt posting at its finest and
then of course that try not to laugh
challenge
so here's seven months ago a year ago a
year ago six months ago so there are a
lot of their recent ones it's just the
top ones are really like long ago this
is really fun I really genuinely enjoyed
reflecting a little bit on the past and
not necessarily cringing just imminent
daring way I felt like that was my most
popular videos have you checked them out
yet what do you think me too
trust me me too you think I want to be
like this huh it's interesting because
you have my you see the difference
everyone changes but it's nice to see
it's nice to see some growth and some
change in in a in a positive way but
also not just completely hating your
past I don't know it's kind of cool like
eight years is a long time I'm lucky to
still be here and I think about that all
the time so thank you everyone I keep
supporting the channel honestly I
wouldn't be here without you and also
double thank you if you buy the merch
all right you're supposed to layer it
okay I spend a lot of time on it please
thank you
it's got Walmart quality bye
[Music]
[Music]
by the marketplace guys